our next featured speaker is dr april
white
and we are really happy to have her here
she's currently the assistant professor
biological science at southeastern
louise louisiana university dr wright
has several currently funded projects in
the lab on deep time evolutionary
dynamics in a variety of groups of
organisms
secondary focus in the right lab is
domain-based education research in
computational biology and how biology
undergraduate students learn computation
and mathematics
dr wright i can't wait to hear what a
bayesian model is and the latest
fashions they're wearing oh that
probably isn't the right kind of model
right i'll stop guessing and let you go
on go right ahead
all right thank you um really happy to
be here today uh i'm gonna try and uh
put this into slideshow mode and see if
you can still see me advancing
all right can you guys see me advance my
slide or are you still seeing the time
can and we can hear you just fine
everything's good perfect uh all right
well thank you so much for having me
uh it's really nice to be here today
uh so today i'm a little bit of a
different type of scientist than um your
other past couple of speakers um so i'll
be talking a little bit about uh some of
the mathematical modeling that we do in
the lab uh there actually won't be any
genomic data um in this particular talk
uh and instead we'll be focusing on
what we do with models and and how we
can do that confidently i just realized
i have the wrong year uh in my in my
slide it is not
2021
but it's been it feels like it's been a
lot of years lately so that's fine like
i said i'm a little bit of a different
biologist than um the other speakers in
this session i don't really do very much
in the way of genomics um
and in this lab we predominantly work on
complex and particularly hierarchical
models for estimating phylogenetic trees
particularly from
the integration of a variety of data
sources
uh and elia had asked me a little bit to
talk about how i ended up interested in
something like this
uh and i didn't start interested in uh
phylogenetics at all in fact um
so when i went to college i started
taking intra bio classes uh
and i was really bored by that um
you know you you memorize the krebs
cycle and and you know you have to know
all this stuff and so i was i was bored
by that um and i ended up
dropping the biology major picking up a
journalism major actually um
but
being the only person on
uh staff who had any sort of
uh stem
background at the newspaper
i got handed a lot of science articles
and this was back in
2006 when a lot of the challenges to
teaching evolution
started to happen
uh so for example uh the dover v kits
miller trial and things like this
uh and so it was a really interesting
time to be
writing about and thinking about
evolutionary biology
and because of that i actually realized
that
biology wasn't just memorizing a bunch
of stuff and regurgitating it onto an
exam
it was a living discipline
and i became interested in the uh
um
you know the role of phylogenetics as
sort of something that would allow you
to study a little bit of everything
right so you can build a phylogeny of
fish you can build a biology of mammals
we work on ants in this lab we work on
stem mammals in this lab we work on
things that have been extinct for 500
million years
we work on things that you could walk
out your front door and collect on your
doorstep
so um i got interested in phylogenetics
because it was this uh
way to get to do everything a little bit
at once as well as a way to sort of uh
engage with the deeper philosophy of
biology
um and when yielding i had a
conversation about this as well
um
uh he wanted me to talk a little bit
about primarily undergraduate
institutions
um
so when i went to college i went to a
undergraduate only institutions anal
college in northfield minnesota uh and i
decided that i really liked sort of that
modality of education uh and i decided
to pursue it following
uh my phd so i've been here at
southeastern louisiana university uh
this is the start of my sixth year as
awarded tenure last year uh and so i
feel like the balance of
responsibilities that i have in this
type of lab is very good i teach three
courses a semester i have a couple
master's students and typically four to
six undergrads in my lab uh and the work
that you're about to see has been sort
of touched on by all
all of those personnel at at least some
points
all right so what we have here are two
phylogenies in panel a this is a
phylogenetic tree that is what we refer
to as not scaled to time
so in this case
typically you're going to see a tree
like this you saw some in the previous
presentation
where
the uh
the branch lengths are usually given in
a rate right the number of substitutions
expected per site so a measure of
you know either the genetic or the
morphological change whatever you happen
to use for your data
on the right hand side
is a phylogeny that has been scaled to
time or what we might call absolute or
geological time
these types of trees allow you to make
like i said absolute or geological
statements about when lineage is
diverged did they diverge 10 million
years ago 5 million years ago 100
million years ago these are the types of
questions that we can answer with a time
scaled tree
and over the next couple slides i'll
show you a couple of applications of
these types of um
uh phylogeny's in the literature
so for example right now
we might all be very familiar with this
this is a screen grab from the website
next strain
where
uh
you know they're tracking different
variants of cobin right and you can see
there's a time axis on the x-axis of
this
uh they're keeping track in absolute and
real-time
of
what strains are arising and how they're
diversifying you can see the different
strains are in different colors here
with some of them labeled
by sort of their common uh
name you can see over time some of them
sort of go extinct some of them uh
continue and diversify so for example
omicron
right now is sort of the dominant strain
and you can see that dominance kind of
over here on the on the right-hand side
of the phylogeny so this is an example
of a time-scaled biogenetic tree
and another example here this is an
example from scallops where they've
built
uh you know phylogenetic tree of
scallops and what they're looking at is
um
you're never looking look closely to
living scallop they're bizarre um they
have a bunch of eyes on them
you can see
by the scale down at your left um the
eye abundance goes from you know black
is like 37 eyes up to 151 eyes in the
blue there and then on the uh kind of
right facing phylogeny phylogeny b
we have the life habit so are they
abyssal do they sit
on on the ground do they really attach
to the ground so cementing do they free
live do they glide do they do other
things
uh and so this is the study this is the
study of trait evolution how does
the evolution of the eye impact the
evolution of life history and these
types of studies typically also assume
um a uh
branch length in sort of millions of
years so absolute or geological time
and so how do we get
a phylogeny with branch links in
millions of years of time
and that is sort of the real question uh
those family of methods that i refer or
that i work with are referred to as the
fossilized birth death model
uh and it has
three different phylogenetic
components for this reason it's been
sometimes referred to as the tripartite
model or the tripartite approach
so under this model we have our data so
our phylogenetic characters these could
be morphological characters these could
be dna characters and we have our fossil
ages and fossil is a little bit of a
general term
if you're working with actual organisms
that might fossilize then yes you have
fossils if you're working with
viral data uh these would just be the
ages of the thing that you isolated so
if you did a blood draw and you found
that somebody uh was carrying hiv and
you wrote down the date
that would be your possible age
and this model has three different
components there's
the substitution model so how your
phylogenetic characters evolve
the clock model which describes the
distribution of evolutionary rates over
time and the tree and tree models and
this describes the process
of diversification that generates your
actual phylogeny
and what i mean by that is this
uh
this part of the model is referred to as
the fossilized bird death we have in the
middle here is this character t
that represents the phylogeny
and you can see there are five different
parameters that are all pointing towards
the phylogeny these are the parameters
that govern the tree shape how many
branches are on the tree so how many
lineages are on the tree
the age of the tree
we're going to walk through them so
right here we have the origin time
when did the process of diversification
that leads to your observed tree start
in your group
the speciation rate is what is the rate
at which new lineages are added to the
phylogeny
the extinction rate is the rate at which
they are removed
the fossilization is
rate is the rate at which we recover
lineages in the past so this could be
via you know sampling viral um
loads this could be
the rate at which fossilization occurs
in your group
and then the sampling probability
of the things that currently exist in
your group
how many of them have we sampled
right this is uh you'll notice that this
probability the sampling probability is
in a square
that refers to this parameter being
fixed we typically assume in this model
uh that you know
how many um
of your plate of interest
you've sampled so if you have
um
you're estimating phylogeny of bears
there is genetic data out there for
every bear you can include every bear in
your sample and so your sampling
probability would be one for many groups
you probably haven't sampled everything
but you might have some good idea of
what proportion of the extant diversity
you've sampled
and different tree shapes are going to
imply
or sorry different model parameters are
going to imply different tree shapes
so for example if we are
[Music]
not including
you know any
um
tip sampling at all that would sort of
imply that we are going to sample
absolutely everything
as we you know increase or um
as we increase our extinction rate that
impacts the tree that we're going that
exists in reality and it impacts the
tree that we can recover from our data
continue on there
right
so i think a lot of us are fairly
familiar with bayes's theorem we have
that right here we have the posterior
probability on the left-hand side of the
equation which is kind of the
probability of parameters given data and
a model
uh
on the right-hand side we have the
likelihood so the probability of the
data given your parameters in a model
any priors you have right prior distrib
probability distributions that specify
uh you know knowledge that you have
about those parameters and that's all
divided by the marginal probability of
the data which is sort of a complicated
uh quantity to get a handle on it i'm
not going to spend too much time on it
here but if you have questions i'm happy
to answer them
so in the case of
the fossilized birth death
in a phylogenetic context that equation
looks something like this
um and there's a lot of stuff on the
screen uh so this is this is a little
bit tricky uh to deal with
and so we're gonna take a look at how we
can sort of break this down usefully
to do good model selection for each of
our three hierarchical sub models
and i'm actually going to present to you
um
uh some results that we have from
actually an entirely paleontological
data set called the sentence these are
an extremely temporally restricted
group of organisms
invertebrates marine invertebrates
and they're found basically from about
500
and 10 million years ago
to about 498 million years ago and
that's it
um
so these have a pretty good amount of
phylogeny characters for a small
invertebrate about 60 characters for
those 27 taxa
um and something that's interesting is
that we have some idea about how diverse
they were over time
um
so i'm going to call your attention to
panel uh
c on this one
where
basically between the first two points
this one down at the origin and then
this one over here at
um
about six million years
there's a huge jump in what we call the
disparity and that's an index of how
different organisms are from one another
and so very early in this group we
accumulate a lot
of
morphological change things begin to
look very different very fast
and so that's a very common pattern in
the fossil record sometimes referred to
as the early burst
and so this might imply something about
our distribution of evolutionary rates
in fact it might imply that
they are very quick at first and then
they slow over time
and so we decided to test four different
molecular clocks the strip clock says
the rates of evolution are the same
all across the tree all through time
probably not true in our case
the autocorrelated clock says well the
rates of an ancestor are
going to be similar to the rates of its
descendants
okay that seems plausible early bursts
like i just said it kind of looks like
our data is that and then the
uncorrelated means an ancestral
descendant can have strongly different
rates of evolution
no limits sky's the limit do whatever
you want
right so again that's sort of a this is
a visual representation of that where
you can see on you know the
autocorrelated generally
the cooler colors are the low rates and
generally you have to kind of pass
through intermediate rates to go from
low rates to high rates
on the uncorrelated clock there you can
see when the branches are colored by
evolutionary rate that you can have
jumping from very low evolutionary rates
to very high ones no problem
right so we had a look at those
um and something that's also the case
here is that we have pretty good
geological information about the time
period when these guys existed
so for example we had pretty rapid
accumulation of lineages here in stage
five
and then slower lineage accumulations in
these stages
and so
um
you know while we might expect
evolutionary rates to change over time
this could potentially also be
implicating the process of
diversification
over time perhaps it's that we're
diversifying very rapidly early on and
therefore accumulating disparity so
perhaps it's not the rate of evolution
but the rate of diversification
and so we took a little bit of a look at
this and got some overall estimates from
extinction rates and origination rates
or speciation rates
uh and this allowed us to sort of have
some idea of ballparks for these sorts
of models so we're able to use these to
place informative prior distributions on
each of these values
and we use a set of models that are
referred to as skyline models which
allow us to have a different kind of
diversification process for each of our
time periods so we had to look at
dividing up the time period into two
chunks
but also three chunks so each of these
individual stages
getting its own diversification process
so we're not totally out to lunch on at
least two of our models
right uh but what about this part here
uh so most of the time we're going to be
working with the mk model of paul lewis
and that's pretty much what we did in
this paper i'm starting to run out of
time so i'm just going to keep moving
um we also looked at you know if feeding
and non-feeding characters evolve
differently
so
from kind of an infinite set of models
that we could have assembled from all
those parameters we were able to distill
down to about 10.
which is great um we used a constant
data set of
fossil and phylogenetic characters
we did all of our estimation or model or
a software called rev phase which is
something that my lab works on for
development
and this allows us to calculate a
precise model likelihood to make
comparisons between models
and what we found is that for each
um
of the hierarchical subcomponents there
was one clear model that was best
all right so for each we could fit
um
a best fit model
uh and use that too and for our
phylogeny so our um uncorrelated log
normal model was the best for the clock
which i was a little bit surprised by
and a model in which we have
diversification changing per stage
was also good
all right um
so this is computationally expensive but
we were able to get things to work a
little bit better by not evaluating
every single model and instead choosing
models that have some prior evidence for
them
right and so when you have these types
of extremely complex models that really
uh calls for a return to hypothesis
driven work right why do we think this
is the right model what is our intuition
telling us
all right so we were able to
estimate a phylogeny but there's some
stuff about this that's intrinsically
unsatisfying so i mentioned
earlier that we could have an early
burst model that manifests in either the
clock or the tree model
what if those interact are these subsets
independent and is it valid to do model
selection on each of them
and my answer is a little bit no
and so
my lab has been piloting what we call
reversible jump model selection this
allows us
to sample the number of model parameters
as part of a markov chain monte carlo
analysis and so in this case we could
have uh subsets of models
being selected at once
so we could be doing the model fitting
for each of our sub models together
rather than separately
so we can sample models simultaneously
to determine
the correct model for all of the
sections together
and finally the other technique that my
lab has been piloting is
the posterior predictive model adequacy
testing these are a family of methods
that allow us to simulate data from our
bayesian posterior predicted or bayesian
posterior distribution and then see if
when we simulate those data they look
like
the empirical data and if they do we
have some test statistics to describe
the goodness of fit there and they're
assumed that then the model is sort of
adequate for the data i'm running out of
time so i'm just going to sum this up
really quickly
with these new hierarchical statistical
models we have non-independence and
model subsections that could be
misleading for our analyses and so we're
kind of looking at evaluating a new
generation of tools for their
effectiveness for dealing with these
sorts of problems
all right so thank you to all of these
um
right lab members and collaborators as
well as to funders and i think i'm out
of time
well not quite you actually have a few
more minutes we have about 10 minutes we
can fill up
so we're going to ask you some on the
spot questions here are you ready yeah
all right again good quit stop sharing
your screen there if you would and uh
that way we can uh be just there you go
now we can see you so a question from
chat and stuff you mentioned that you
are not working with genomic data
that was the least what was understood
how do you validate that model
predictions or how important or even
possible it is to validate the models
yeah so you work with a lot of simulated
data in the lab
uh and try to simulate data that looks
uh
like you know the real data um i mean
and that's exactly the same as you would
do with genomics right um
so we work with a lot of simulated data
for model validation
and then
um we do quite a bit of sensitivity
testing as well so um you know you run
the model and then
you know you take a look at how well
it's
kind of working with your data
and you run it with maybe some different
assumptions and see how much of a
difference that makes to your actual
conclusion
uh and then the other thing that you can
do for kind of model validation would be
the posterior predictive model adequacy
testing which is that very last thing
that i i kind of thought that i was out
of time to discuss but the idea with
this is that you take samples out of
your posterior distribution
simulate data with them
and then uh you use test statistics to
determine how closely the correspondence
is between
um
you know the data that you've you've
simulated under your model and your
empirical data right so they look very
similar according to your test
statistics
then that's you know a good sign that
you're probably modeling the correct
things
okay well thank you
what are the limitations of using
hierarchical basian models
i mean i would say that the limitations
are mostly sort of actually we had an
annual reviews paper that came out on
this last week um but there are there
are lots of limitations and a lot of
those limitations are computational um
so when it comes to bayesian methods you
know we're really looking at the idea of
you know having these models converge to
a stationary distribution where you can
assess that you've drawn enough samples
from the posterior to approximate it
uh that takes a long time in practice uh
for complex models so there's a time
sort of factor and then the computation
time associated with that it's very hard
to do this type of work for example in
the cloud
so if you don't have you know a server
or an hpc unit
a lot of this isn't at this point kind
of out of your reach um it's not
something that can effectively be done
via aws or anything like that
uh so there's that that's a big
limitation
uh another limitation is sort of the
uh
the quality of information that you can
come up with right so let's say you have
um
you know genomic data
but there's no fossils in your group
your ability to have any sort of
resolution in the past is therefore
extremely limited and there are some
groups where that's true fish for
example are one where
because of the nature of sort of the
sedimentology and how they get deposited
it's pretty hard to tell when a fish is
from um
uh other soft bodied organisms
are also quite tricky
um
but you know if you're working with
something like disease biology you often
have a lot of extremely high certainty
data because you know what day the
patient came in
and you sampled their flu strain right
uh so in the biomedical realm methods
like this are often extremely effective
um
and actually one of the founders of this
kind of series of methods uh was on
swiss national tv every week for the
coronavirus update because they were the
ones who were tracking it um
so you encounter a lot less limitations
when you're looking over the short time
scales like a couple hundred years or a
couple thousand years for a disease
bearing organism i think the other big
limitation is
just
your ability to think about all of these
things at once um
you know it's it's complicated
uh it really is and
developing the statistical literacy the
computational literacy knowing each of
your data sources and its individual
limitations that's a lot to ask of
anyone
uh so i think
yeah just our ability with human brains
to think about these things is is
considered my greatest
been my greatest impression over the
last two days is just how everybody's
keeping all this even remotely close to
what they can think of okay here we got
one from chat can the models be used to
determine gene evolution for potential
vaccine candidates for tick species
i mean i don't see why not um
so for a long time phylogenetics event
has been a component of um
the flu vaccine uh selection
right and so uh
this is initially described back in the
early augs with uh
mike warby at all where they would show
that you know you would get oftentimes
kind of a trunk lineage that would give
rise to the flu strains for that year
uh and so phylogenetics has a deep kind
of um
history with that and they typically do
that based on a couple of loci
associated with sort of the uh host
genome evasion
um
response and so
uh yeah definitely i think that sort of
thing is is very possible so um
you can build individual gene
phylogenies and see what they're telling
you that might be
different than the whole kind of species
tree uh so oftentimes there's conflict
between what individual genes will tell
you versus when you look at them all
together what they'll tell you
but those techniques are very well
explored and so i think that would
absolutely be possible yeah
okay thank you what are the ways you can
combine hierarchical basin trees with
other methods like your standard
neighbor joining tree etc
you can't
there we go that was a simple answer
yeah i don't really like to give answers
that simple but um
yeah
it doesn't work with neighborhood okay
here's another one from chat have they
used k nearest neighbor models against
real data for synthesizing data has this
included both clinical and omnics data
omics data for example using cynthia
patient data with 1kg genome data or
using uk biobank data with clinical
phenotypes etc
i have never heard of any of that
so you and me both so we're potentially
someone else yeah
all right very good
um if it has limitations then what is
the biggest motivation to use it
well i mean everything has
limitations right
i mean if we didn't do things that had
limitations
you know
you wouldn't have a computer right like
um
we wouldn't be in this manner in stone
would make this very interesting right
so what prompted you to focus what
prompted you to focus on this specific
topic of research and did you consider
other domains also why did you
get this direction
yeah so for me um
you know i think like most kids they
grew up watching you know dinosaur tv
shows and reading books about dinosaurs
and you think you might want to be a
paleontologist but um
you know that's
that's a pretty tough career path um
whereas going into
the computational side of things you
know you get to do a lot of different
things um
in a day and so you know when i was
first thinking about you know
evolutionary biology seriously as a
career path um
you know i looked at lots of
different things you know functional
traits studies um
you know eco kind of evolutionary
ecological studies
all sorts of stuff like that um
but then as
i started to think about kind of well
how do we integrate those things
together uh you know phylogenetics kind
of kept coming up as sort of the
organizing framework in which we study
the evolution of traits and organisms
and so i got interested in phylogenetics
that way and then
you know the statistical problems that
we have
uh in phylogenetics are extremely
difficult uh and hard problems keep us
in jobs and heart problems are
interesting and so
that's how i ended up here
nice well we're within a minute of our
official closing times instead of
potentially starting another question
that we can't answer and and working
into emmanuel's time i'm just going to
thank you for a fascinating interesting
uh decision making modeling and how it
all relates thank you so much for being
here today we really appreciate your
time
thank you for having me
you're welcome